now that Iowa and New Hampshire are over
all the candidates are turning their
attention to Nevada excited about that
yeah you just answered the question for
me we're in California and unless you're
in Nevada I think even if you're in
Nevada you're not sure and it's a caucus
coming up in Nevada I think that's got
people worried yeah yeah yeah the Nevada
caucus says they will not use the same
app used by the Iowa caucus I think yeah
okay that's uh that's right you're gonna
go with tinder
you know what a good night last night
amy klobuchar had a good night last
night she's doing very well yeah yeah
and don't be hurt
I'll shy you know I like a lot this is
interesting
Amy Klobuchar is rise in the polls is
being called Clos mentum that's right
yeah and Joe Biden's campaign is being
called pretty much clover it's uh it's
come out that Amy Klobuchar has written
two books this is impressive yeah I
suppose to her opponent Michael
Bloomberg who often stands on two books
just use that that's just use the
payphone which no one's done in twenty
20 years I think two candidates dropped
out of the race last night Andrew Yang
and Michael Bennett yeah yeah Andrew
yang told his supporters thank you for
this amazing ride while Michael Bennett
told his supporters come on son let's go
home
you